President Trump told the g7 today that
he thinks India and Pakistan will be
able to resolve their dispute over
Kashmir without his help India's Prime
Minister Narendra Modi also told the
meeting that Kashmir was a bilateral
issue but Pakistan has sought
international help tensions have been
rising between the two countries since
India removed the region's special
status at the beginning of August
Oh Kashmir stateís has been contested
ever since British rule ended in 1947
India administers the southern and
eastern portions the line of control
established in 1949 separates the
Pakistan controlled areas to the north
and west and China administers the
region to the north and the east
joining me now to discuss this is the
British boxer Amir Khan who has family
in Pakistan and friends in Kashmir and
he says he wants to visit the line of
control next week a very warm welcome to
you thanks for coming to join us on the
program this evening and why have you
decided to do this
I'm wondering if we've got our
communications there with you mayor very
warm welcome to the program I just
wanted to ask you why you've decided to
take this step well I've done recon
Foundation and that's one of the reasons
I probably want to go there do some
charity work and help the people on the
LLC which is a line of control in on the
PacSun side I've not been in Kashmir but
I've been hearing a lot of big problems
I've been happening over there so
obviously got me nothing it's all about
in the awareness out people that was I
really happy know there and what are
your concerns in particular I think my
concerns are like people in Kashmir
being killed these are innocent people
have been killed the schools are closed
so they can't really get on with these
big things the disputes all left off
there's ami there the the innocent
people are being killed and being hurt
and injured injured as well at the same
time so I wanna go that can't build
awareness and foundation myself I
wouldn't go and try show my software and
also build awareness I mean you know in
this day and age I mean things I never
really hear about and I think by just
raising my voice and taking a stand to
this I'm going to Pakistan and seeing it
on my own eyes so that when I do come
back that body while Lily saw hasn't
been affected relations do you think
here in the UK between British
Pakistanis and British Indians yes I
mean I don't think between the platforms
and India's in England I don't think
made any big difference but you could
see that everyone is you announced that
you're going to make this trip to the
line of control on Twitter there has
been quite a bit of backlash on there
just scrolling through and I was having
a look earlier on a lot of Indian
critics in particular some of them
suggesting that you were trying to use
this as an opportunity for publicity
what do you say to that not all I mean
it's going to a line of controls a very
dangerous place and obviously I'm my
life too is at risk
I'm going there just and raise that
awareness on what we is happening there
in Moscow
I mean you know he's a very dangerous
place I'm going there for Felicity
something I'm never really gonna I've
also gone to many other places around
the world or Charlie out my foundation
where I really want to get the word out
what's happening
and if I can go ahead and call people
and raise up attention on what's
happening over there that's what my
really that's what my thought is of
doing you know go in there and helping
more than more than just going there
just to make a name for myself